I got six chickens the other day no way
I'm a farmer dude let's go
talk about the hose I was like yeah
I want a lot of chicks in my girl I I've
had a girl for like eight years oh okay
and I've always wanted a lot of chicks
and she's like well I kind of got your
dream got a great dream but she lets you
yeah yeah yeah
I mean let because it's like she doesn't
necessarily have that you know I've
always been like yeah my own person yeah
you know when I first met Danny I'm like
okay I don't get like marriage like
marriage is stupid and just like the
concept of it [__] one chick for the
rest of life stupid I don't like that
um so that's like one of our first
conversations we ever had when I met her
like we weren't even like talking like
we were liking each other I don't
remember why but I was like marriage is
dumb right it's funny like vividly
remember having that conversation with
her and uh now I'm married
[Laughter]
it's like hey I'm in New York if hot
chicks like hey I wanna [__] suck you
yeah
I know you're not
I think the reason it works for us is
because I treat her truly like a queen I
really do take care of her and and I
obviously Kings has I [__] I provide
for her not just financially but like
emotionally like we still have great sex
I think that's important for you know
guys like I want to [__] other chicks
like when's the last time you [__]
your girl good like well it's been you
know so we have good sex we we cuddle we
have we're like I stay there every night
I sleep there every night every morning
it's not like oh am I coming home
tonight like I live a very strict
lifestyle she's a part of it and uh you
know I think it works because there's
rare times people think I'm [__]
chicks all the time it's not like that
it's it's the random Ka I'm in [__]
New York like if I want to hook up with
the chick and it's not gonna be a big
deal I gotta be safe You Gotta Be You
Know wear protection I wanna you know
he's putting out the bad signal right
now
are we live right now I'm in New York I
think it works because I do treat her
the way she deserves to be treated and I
wouldn't even be in this position
without her because she's literally like
my like
she's my rock and she keeps me super I
would be so much more distracted with
trying to get chicks if I didn't have
the life I have right now with her and I
and I tell her like I want to be with we
have a baby I want to be with you you
know forever is a long word or big word
but I want to be with you until until we
don't want to be with each other I can't
see that really ever happening yeah but
I do like to say like I plan on being I
want more kids with you like I love you
I truly love you I'm a horny
[__]
honest conversations how it goes I let
her know how guys think most you ever
tell her about about like yeah if you
[__] something crazy oh go go I got a
phone either I was at the sign uh picked
autograph signing picture thing in
Houston once and I was just sharing like
the people would tag me and I would
share it on my eyes because I think it's
cool they think it's cool fans think
it's cool if you share it on your own
[__] so I was sharing a bunch a cute
girl I didn't really think anything of
it at the time I was like oh she's cute
and uh which is rare usually I'm on it
like hey what's up
and Danny Danny messaged me she's like
yo you should try to smash my girl
message me wow I didn't even hit that I
hit her up after I'm like well [__] it
like yeah yeah and smashed and it was
incredible and it was such a great
experience and I experienced that
because Danny told me to smash so I
thought I was pretty fast you want to
hear Deets uh she didn't ask for to hear
deeds and it's not easy for her
emotionally like it's not like she's
just good at it yeah but she's all we've
grown so much from these experiences
um me hooking up with yeah what a spin
you just put on that we've grown from me
[__]
[__] Queen
[__] she's
like she's like a rare I feel like I
lucked out so much fine then it's
finding someone like her so you travel a
lot you're training I don't travel a lot
while you're training all the time
trying a lot can she do her thing uh the
way you know until Andrew Tate came
along I was like you can and then you
say it's like girls can't do that I'm
like yeah [__] that yeah you had to
become a Top Gear I'm a top gee so no
she can't no I think uh it just makes
sense like hey we got this dope life if
you want to go and risk it for something
and like I provide you with everything
what she wants is stability she wants to
feel love she I give her everything she
feel uh she wants so I'm marking all the
boxes she doesn't [__] Danny doesn't
go out she's straight up from Oaxaca in
Mexico she's a real Mexican yeah she's a
Mexican Queen she doesn't go out she
doesn't do anything she does hair she's
very passionate about hair she does
Jujitsu she trains with us and uh she's
a mom so her she the last thing
you're so confident in the relationship
you're like yeah yeah she's not that's
the last thing on her mind she's like
grossed out by it and I can see how
girls like one hook up with random guys
it's different guys [__] use their
dicks like they're fine yeah so it is
different um there was a point where I
did say I'm like hey do you and I want I
have this Freedom you have the freedom
too I've never really told her she
doesn't but
you don't feel like she wants suicide
yeah but we've had conversations about
it though what what about
have there ever been any chicks in the
DMS that you were like
a fan of
before
hmm that's a good asset
I like that question no did you beat off
to any girls that dm'd you no but I
would wait I'll be I've been looking in
the idea I was like where you at girls
no nothing crazy nothing crazy yet a
little blue check situation I mean I
don't [__]
I have 98 male audience so the girls in
the DMS are pretty pretty rare to be
honest dick pics I don't think I've
actually seen any dick pics in the DMV
what's your number
[Music]
I see a guy sent me a photo I don't open
it so maybe
they did I had this like sex therapist
guy I was talking to and he made a
comment that you were putting him on
your podcast yeah it was on the scene
yeah
yeah Jesus man yeah no I had a closed
door conversation with the sexual God
and he made a comment that is kind of I
don't know maybe controversial but he
said professional fighters are naturally
the best love makers he said in his
experience that he's [__] a lot he's
been around gang bangs and [__] he's
like mind-body Connection in terms of
like being able to like withstain like
erection and [__] like that is better
naturally because you're in the ring
getting punched in the head able to like
mentally deal with a stressful situation
in your body trying to react a certain
way and overpower the natural things you
think that's true or not I think they're
maybe I don't know about that what's he
gonna say today there's a certain level
of alpha you have as a fighter yeah that
maybe can translate
one time for a little Dominique a couple
times
be honest are you are you like able to
pull guards
the doorbell rung one time doorbell
[Laughter]
and then she's waxing your [__] yeah
[Music]
no he didn't ask but like I I was it was
I was a crack at it and I was running
out of a building so I was uh I was
naked and then I was like yo before I do
this I kind of got to tell you guys
something like I have a very hairy ass
like and that might not be what you guys
imagine on camera and uh and then he was
like all right show me and uh I showed
him and then he came up and he like
touched my cheek oh oh you guys like
dude you didn't need to do that that was
some like director institution or a
crackhead though in the roll so it was
yeah yeah
he whacked me in my ass
no uh no so then I I went and got waxed
in some like uh Ukrainian woman waxed my
ass and it wasn't that bad I mean did
you like the aftermath that's great
wiping is incredible the toilet paper
doesn't bundle up I got a bidet oh you
oh but that's a game changer yeah it
really is do you ever go reverse cowgirl
on the bidet and just hit that one oh
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
okay so the ultimate dream is double
champ
100 Mil in a bank you mean threesome is
that what you mean
I've got lots of threesomes that's the
thing who gets the nut
both well there's been it depends on the
sprinkler system if your girl is
involved your wife is involved she has
to get it right dude she gets off of me
[__] another chick
but does she want where'd you find
that's Queen
this whole time she's been upset
no uh yeah the nut it's just kind of
however I'm feeling I get a pick no top
G gets picked
that's never an issue yeah it's never
been an issue and we've hooked up with
other chicks she's always been very
comfortable and and again it's like it's
because our relationship's so solid that
we can do stuff like that it's not like
we're fighting and then I'm like hey
let's [__] this chick and Danny's like
okay it's always like we're in a really
good spot and then we can yeah but do
you ever feel bad for the other girl
like she did all that work for that nut
and then she doesn't even get it no no I
don't feel bad for her
I feel bad if I don't last that's what
sucks wait what do you mean you bust
before the girl even oh there's been
times when I have been I just busted too
fast I'm like hey
that's because the leopards or some [__]
yeah
it makes a little sense too it's
Evolution bro that's why we broadcast
but I always usually tell them like wait
for the next round give me five give me
ten because oh you run it back in 10
minutes if it's a three Banger and it's
a new chick and it's like yeah you can
get fat like give it like no offense but
if you [__] a girl so many times how
many times when we bust you're good for
the day you're good yeah but the new
chick you're like and you didn't perform
like I got you hit the perennial nerve
we need a rebatch yeah that's it but you
really apologize or do you just have
really yeah do you ever like fake nut
and just go to the bathroom no I think
not we're just like nut but like yeah
and then go to the bathroom and be like
oh guys I got it um
[Laughter]
there's been times for sure okay tell me
the apology this is really fun to set
the stage
not a bad one I'd say hey you're I'm
sorry you're just I want to [__] you so
long you're so hot like and it just
happened I'm sorry wait so you were
already [__] her and your girls there
yeah does she also go like no she just
doesn't really have anything else
sometimes like honestly doing some
breath work before just Mind Body like
whatever you know what I'm saying try to
like kind of connect with yourself but
for the most part that fresh that new
Puss is it's tough you ever have Tim
just stand in the corner and watch him
yeah give you advice
[Music]
oh no I haven't haven't had that yet
Tim man yeah what a life you're living
do you do you recognize that your life
is different than 99.9 of humans in
history sometimes I try to I try to you
know kind of reflect like damn this is
[__] crazy it's easy to not though
just keep going keep going keep going
but yeah I definitely try to reflect and
you know that's times when I'm sitting
in the hot tub cold plunge like by
myself I just need a time for myself
which I do have a lot of and I think
that's important
um just for you know especially for
athletes in Camp kind of like
visualization or or uh you know
connecting with your higher Spirit or
whatever but just to be healthy happy
human just reflected on life